is there a connection with life
insofar as human
beings do not begin to question the meaning of life only
in situations of extreme need but also
in the opposite case, namely where
everything is primitive and
needs are met,
especially when in a
wealthy society or a
welfare state then sometimes breaks open this inner
emptiness and the person concerned
asks himself why all these people what all
this external happiness for i would like to
know what it is you can formulate
at the extremes lead to illnesses
or can lead to illnesses the
extreme need but also the satisfaction
of  correct but only insofar as one
also considers that in and of itself
the feeling of meaninglessness is not an illness
is not new pants or not cute at all
but it can lead to it but it
can lead to
barbara wagner in Freistadt work
street 13 ask here you can also as a
layman  fellow human beings according to your method also
help  the layman can help his fellow human beings in the process of finding
meaning,
but one must not forget that
sometimes a crisis of meaning and value is the
outward sign of something that is
actually behind it and that can
very well be a neurosis, under certain circumstances
even a psychosis, so
it has to be one
a person can only actually get a
diagnosis there is no therapy without
a previous diagnosis and this
diagnosis can actually only be made by a
specialist but if it
turns out that it is
not a pathological
finding then of course everyone can do a
lot more for their fellow human beings, even as a layperson
than that there is even
help myself i know
hundreds of people
who have found reading a book on this
subject to have been
able to cope with the crisis of meaning alone being aware of the problem
is a help
really being aware of the problem above all
not least the feeling of a certain
solidarity that this senselessness
g  efeeling this crisis of meaning actually
connects you with the best examples of
humanity, because such people
manifest intellectual
honesty and sincerity by
not simply accepting something from the hands of tradition
in response and accepting it,
but
wanting to wrestle
for it ourselves independently produces for wagner in the free state even
more  the question of whether there is an area
in the human being where one
feels particularly
understood, i.e. the question of
human contact where
human contact is
established, the question of meaning is not explicit here,
but implicit, that is to say in the
poem when a  person
feels lovingly bound or lovingly has
the feeling of togetherness with
another then the epz ii
is already solved by this fact the 7 question in
a certain sense because
love is one aspect of possible are
fit i think that is part of the
answers  given that adolf matitschka
offers as in 57 brunnengasse 36 at
home armani comes here to the
statements that there are three things that have to be
considered as essential to the meaning of life
firstly that man is
a biological being for whom it is enough
to satisfy his drives and  means
here is life that makes sense
can you follow this statement anja
sie i would like to
register a few reservations
insofar as in my
opinion it is part of the nature of being human that it
increasingly points to
something that is not itself again  does that
mean something in the service of which
man gives up or exactly it points
to a person to a partner whom
one should if a group is not given to the
people one loves as a
team in other words only there is a
human being fully human where he is  self
forgets and overlooks and
disregards in the service of a cause or in
the love of a person if abe  r if
that's the case, then it's not
just a human being and then you'll also be happy
, unintentionally and intentionally quite
automatically, and the
reverse happens when you're lucky,
i like my constant comment, the
more you feel like it  is about you
more of gcm you can see that most
clearly basics indiscriminate the more
a male patient tries
to demonstrate his potency, the greater
the probability that he is
doomed to impotence and vice versa, the
more a female patient
cares about whether she is now
is capable of a full orgasm, the greater the
chances are that it will end with fragility
i think that was the answer to
the two dramatic question here it was
about the finding that
human beings are social beings,
which means a part  the
meaning of mutual help
or can be seen mr mateschitz in
his triad here then d  he
determination as a psychological being
man has the possibility to use the
gifts of nature and the achievements
of culture and sees as
if they are the fulfillment of the
longing for freedom yes but free
because joy is the effect of
self-devotion to people or things
and if you now make it your
goal you can't
find it beautifully expressed anywhere from a
poem by gore the indian
poetic philosopher who says i
slept and dreamed life was
joy
i expect and saw life was
duty i worked and she was
duty  was joy there has also been
read before yes what so frankl for we have
now as the last to send in
as the last to send gerhard
breier at home in Groß harras in lower austria
i had to give it back in an abbreviated
version the examiner
has advised it so far  this is about the
question of how far the religion goes as far as possible for
people  d has conveyed the meaning and purpose of
the loss has
now created a vacuum for many people
and how far the people in
their songs hold crises that are perhaps influenced
by this loss yes
that is certainly correct and there is a
word that of a German psychiatrist
the emigration
of occidental humanity from
pastoral care to neurologists was shaped by this
problem of course today’s
psychiatrist or psychotherapist has to
face
them you mustn’t forget every age has
its neurosis and every age needs its
psychotherapy and today
psychotherapy has to turn to those
states that are there at the moment  by sigmund
freud and by alfred adler there was hardly any
sense of
this senselessness today this task falls to the doctor or
the psychotherapist and within
this
branch to the logotherapist to a significant extent insofar as
the logotherapy has a specific
indication area, i.e. specifically
indicated  is precisely in those neuroses
that I have called neurosis that
can be traced back to this senseless feeling
as soon as this
senseless feeling manifests itself as clinical
symptoms then
logotherapy is indicated but you must
not forget that according to internationally
agreed
independent estimates
the percentage is such  lies and roses
today, at least 20 percent on average,
professor franke
, despite the oil crisis, we are currently
developing more into a
prosperous society towards a
society that strives for the possession of
technical and other goods
that has written on its banners that more and more have more
at their disposal
do you mean that we are
also developing down into an abyss
insofar as today's society is by
and large geared towards satisfying
practically all human
needs, and some needs
even generate bew  usst only creates a
need comes up empty
that is the most human of all
human needs that is the
need for meaning
that is the will to see not to
name that and if not
in good time psychotherapy or
even psychology in their
motivation trainer recognizes that the
human being in the  being basically a being
in search of meaning, then of
course he will not only be sexually frustrated as before,
but now also
existentially frustrated and
remain progress and the consequence
is the rising suicide figures
in all countries that are related to
prosperity or welfare
said sparkle